one of the biggest shifts that i had as
an entrepreneur going from you know
making a few hundred thousand dollars a
year a million dollars a year to making
you know just 10 or nine figures like we
do now has been um a simple
understanding that i'm trying to hit at
a couple different ways and hopefully
you'll be able to shift your perspective
in terms of how you see product and
delivery
and so right now if you're not making
the amount of money that you want to
make it's because the product you have
is not good enough and it's it's really
hard to confront that fact but if you
really do and sit here i can't tell you
the amount of times i talk to
entrepreneurs and they're like man if i
just had more people if more people
would just find out about my product
then all my problems would be solved but
the reality is that if you have any
amount of customers then people already
have found out about your product and
for one reason or another they have
chosen not to tell anyone else about it
and you have to sit with that for a
second you have to realize that like
people have found out about your product
and they're not referring people and you
have to ask why
why are these people not sending me
business and so one of the one of the
first times i heard a statement that i
really liked about this was from dan
kennedy and he said
most small entrepreneurs try and get
customers to make sales
bigger entrepreneurs
try to make sales to get customers
and the difference is one person is all
about trying to get to the money as fast
as possible what do i need to say to get
this person say yes what i need to say
to get this person to buy right how do i
get the money right
the other way is how do i make some sort
of exchange so that i can now create a
long time relationship with this
customer and continue to provide value
over time one has a compounding
view and perspective on time and value
and the other is short-sighted and i can
tell you the difference between the
people who are millionaires that i have
that i'm friends with and people who are
billionaires that i am friends with this
is probably one of the most fundamental
differences
and so i was talking to a friend of mine
who's worth of rebellion and he was
saying if it's not going to grow on its
own over time it's not worth doing
and i really sat with that for a second
and it was like
if if i
if you put in a one-time effort like
this is what this is how people who are
the ultra wealthy think if you put
one-time effort into something
and it compounds over time then that is
an enterprise or product that they want
to continue to invest in
on the flip side if you have to
consistently show up and consistently
promote and consistently get out there
and sell and sell and do all this stuff
then what ends up happening is that the
product itself is not good enough right
because people in and of themselves are
not referring business and so let me let
me give you three questions that really
changed and hopefully will alter your
perspective like they did mine around
product and service
and so the first is
if i have an existing product or service
and i were to make it 10 times more
expensive so really think about the
price so or you can say a hundred
thousand dollars or a million dollars
whatever it is right just a huge number
and if that's how much i were charging
for it what would i need to do
what would the experience need to be
what would the product need to deliver
in order for it to be worth that much
what happens is you start thinking in a
very different type of mindset about how
much value you have to create right and
so that is the first question that i ask
there's two more and the third one's my
favorite and i'll get to in a second
the second question i ask
is
if this product that i have cost
one-tenth as much as it does right now
but i had to make it better than it
currently is
what would i need to do what one-time
assets would i need to create that would
consistently provide value that i could
do at scale that could i could do
profitably right so
first question if this were 10 times
expensive or 100 000 or a million
dollars is what i charge for my product
what
would it need to be what would the
experience need to be and what value
would i need to deliver in order for it
to be worth that much
the second question is if it were
one-tenth
the cost but i had to make it better
than my current product or service what
else would i create or do or make in
order to facilitate that outcome
and the third question which is probably
my favorite which i think underpins the
entire ideology that that i'm hitting on
here is if i had a business and i were
only allowed to sell one more customer
and the rest of the growth of my
business had to come from that customer
without me asking as in that that
customer's experience was so remarkable
was so positive was so amazing that they
they
alone had to on their own volition tell
other people about my service
what would need to happen
what would need to happen to create that
experience
and when thinking about all three of
these product frames i like them because
they kind of hit on different aspects of
the product the first question which is
a hundred thousand dollar million dollar
question
hits on value which is how do i create
the most value in the product itself
the second question hits on the profit
of the product because if it's one tenth
of cost and i have to make it better
this means i don't have to do high
margin one-time investment type things
to make the entire product more valuable
right so that hits on profit so first is
the value of the product the second is
the profit to me right as a business
owner and then the third question hits
on the experience which is what's the
customer experience which is everything
else that surrounds the product that
we're selling or service that we're
selling right what is the experience
that has to occur in order for this
customer to become a raving fan that
it's so good that they remark about it
they cannot help themselves but remark
about it
and what's interesting is that every
super wealthy person that i know pretty
much exclusively talks about product and
usually the really small people that i
know only talk about promotion
and promotion should really only exist
to get your product right and then once
it is right then you can juice it and
then let it go and take care of itself
and the reason that it's so important at
least in my opinion
is that if you think about the six ways
of getting customers right and if you
don't know what those are it's paid
media earned media so paid media's
advertising right in promotions uh
earned media is followings right if you
have any kind of organic following the
third is through your contact list so
people on your phone and your email list
et cetera you already own their contact
information the fourth is through manual
outbound so that's dms cold emails cold
calls cold all of that stuff where you
reach out to people
the fifth is through affiliates so
partners who can promote your stuff and
the sixth which is the most powerful and
the only one that compounds
is word of mouth
so think about that for a second every
of the other five ways of acquiring
customers
is not compounding those are linearly
scaled right it means if you double the
amount of outbound people you have you
double the amount of customers that you
get if you double your ad spend you
might be able to double the amount of
customers you get sometimes it's less
than that but you get the idea they
skill relatively linearly right
whereas word of mouth referrals which is
the sixth way of getting customers is
the only one that compounds it
multiplies rather than is additive all
right if you get two people to tell two
people and those people tell two people
then it continues to compound and that
is what creates enterprise value that is
what creates an enduring thing and that
is what when you spend the extra time to
make the product so good that people
have to tell their friends about it
then that's where you get the unending
scale and also is where all the profit
is right you don't have to worry about
the turn as much because the product's
so good you don't have to worry about
the negative reviews because the
product's so good you don't have to
worry about customers badminton because
instead they're telling their friends
about how good you are and
this has been one of the shifts that has
been most helpful for me and honestly
what i when i look back on my own
trajectory how much i talk about
promotion in the beginning of my career
versus now i talk so much more about
people and product the real nuts of this
is that
everything that the ultra wealthy do is
compounding
it grows with time where time becomes an
asset instead of a liability and if
everything you do you have to go out and
get more business go out and get more
business go out and get more business
right it means that it requires effort
every single day whereas if you put a
lot of front-end effort which is the
investment which is the patience right
to make the thing that much better in
the beginning
then it will pay you in dividends over
time and most people skip that step
because they just want to make the first
sale they're just trying to get a
customer to make a sale rather than
trying to make a sale to get a customer
and so um anyways i hope you found this
valuable um i cover this stuff uh in in
my book which is basically free it's 99
cents it's the cheapest i could let
amazon
do it it's called 100 million offers if
you want to grab it i'm donating the 35
cents that amazon gives you
like it gives me um it's for you guys
it's everything that i've learned about
how to create offers that uh are so good
people feel stupid saying no um i think
it's the number one seller in
advertising and direct marketing on
amazon right now um
love you all hope you got value from
this if you did hit that subscribe
button and i'll see you guys in the next
video lots of love catch you soon bye